WebEx is the recommended tool for
office hours and
teleconferences in the OMS program.
>> Some classes use Hangouts,
Hangouts On Air and other tools.
But WebEx comes most highly recommended
because it supports both one-to-one and
one-to-many meetings, and
because it supports client-side
recording at meetings.
>> To access WebEx go
to gatech.webex.com.
Click on the top right to log in.
To host a teleconference,
click this button.
Then, send your guest this link.
The first time you use the tool,
you'll go through some initial set
up based on your operating system.
Then, once you're in,
you'll need to click Connect to
Audio over here to enable audio.
After that, you can click on your
microphone to mute or unmute yourself.
You can click this icon
to turn on your webcam.
You can also invite people and
get the meeting URL using these buttons.
Or, you can enable screen
sharing with this button.
Lastly, you can use the Record
button to record the meeting.
As the presenter, you have a number of
options for how to control the room.
More commonly though, you'll be joining
rooms run by your instructors and TAs.
So let's see what that's like.
I'm going to join David's room.
I click the link to his
meeting that he sent me.
Then I click enter room
the same way I did before.
After joining I would need
to enable my audio by either
clicking Yes when prompted or
by clicking Connect to Audio.
If these options don't appear,
the presenter hasn't yet enabled audio.
After that,
I'll be in the same type of room but
since I'm not the presenter most
of the options will be disabled.
But I'll still mute and
unmute myself, or turn on and
off my webcam the same way.
>> These WebEx rooms are only
open if the presenter is in them.
But if you join them before
the presenter arrives
you'll be automatically put in
the conference once they're there.
Typically, your instructors and
TAs will schedule office hours.
And when office hours roll around you
can just click the link to enter their
room and wait for them to arrive.
Web X also supports a waiting room
of sorts in case the instructor or
TA wants to have private one-on-one
office hours with a series of people.
If that's the case you'll automatically
be put into the conference once
the instructor or TA is ready for you.